القائمة. روسيا تواصل تهديد
الغرب وامريكا والغرب لا يتوقفون
ردا على اطلاق صاروخ. وذكرت
مصادر اعلامية عبرية ان نحو اربع
عن دعم اوكرانيا وتستمر الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية حتى هذه
منطقة مفتوحة في الجليل الاعلى
بعد اطلاقه من جنوب لبنان. وفي
على الحدود اللبنانية. تقاعس في
الغرب والمانيا وفرنسا على رأس
لبنان باتجاه شمال اسرائيل. واكد
جيش الاحتلال سقوط صاروخ في
عبدالمجيد تبون حظر تصدير المواد
الغذائية الاساسية كالسكر والزيت
للاستهلاك المحلي قررت الحكومة
الجزائرية بامر من الرئيس
تطور لاحق اعلن جيش الاحتلال ان
مدفعيته قصفت اهدافا في لبنان
عملية اخلاء لاجلاء الجرحى
والمدنيين من ماريبول. حيث يزداد
روسيا خلال مكالمة هاتفية مع
الزلنسكي. قال اردوغان يجب تنظيم
والمعكرونة والسميد ومشتقات
القمح. اطلاق صاروخين من جنوب
الدفاع الروسية تعلن مخزن
للاسلحة الغربية قرب مدينة
ثمانية اشهر في الوقت الذي اكد
فيه ضمان استمرار صادرات الغاز
الجزائري الى اسبانيا. وبسبب
الحرب الاوكرانية وارتفاع اسعار
الغذاء عالميا. ولتفادي اي ضغط
داخليا على الطلب وارتفاع مفاجئ
عبدالمجيد تيبون ان بلاده تمتلك
مخزونا من القمح يكفي لمدة
اسلحة دمار شامل في اوكرانيا
واتهام روسيا بها. الاستخبارات
الوضع حزنا كل يوم بحسب الرئاسة
التركية. قال الرئيس الجزائري
وثلاثين قذيفة اطلقتها المدفعية
الاسرائيلية صوب مناطق مفتوحة
البريطانية الدفاعات الجوية
والبحرية الاوكرانية تعيق تقدم
ثلاثين الى اربعين عاما. شركة
ميكسار تنشر صورا تظهر ما انها
المتفوق حدث تاريخي سيضمن الامن
لاطفال واحفاد روسيا لمدة بين
مليون دولار لمساعدتها في مواجهة
العملية الروسية ضد اوكرانيا.
اوديسا طالب ديمترو كوليبا
بتصنيف روسيا دولة راعية
للارهاب. موسكو تعلن عن
استفزازات امريكية لاستخدام
لخنادق طولها اربعون مترا قد
تصبح مدافن للقتلى. بعد قصف
اوديسا. بوتين يوجه رسائل الى
دول الغرب ويتهمها بمحاولة تدمير
الروس برغم زيادة موسكو لنشاطها
العسكري في اوكرانيا. هولندا
اكثر من اربعمائة مهمة نارية
خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة. روسيا
ادنى من التدريب لمشغلي المسيرات
ذوي الخبرة. فكيف سترد روسيا على
سارمات المختبرة حديثا والقادرة
على توجيه ضربات نووية للولايات
بلاده زودت حتى الان اوكرانيا
باسلحة قيمتها مليار وستمائة
الهاتف وعبر الرسائل وخلال فترة
محددة تم اغلاق حتى الخروج من
مقبرة جماعية ثانية قرب ماريبول.
كما اظهرت ميكسار ايضا صورا
انها تعتزم نشر صواريخها
الباليستية العابرة للقارات
المتحدة بحلول الخريف المقبل.
واكدت موسكو ان اطلاق هذا السلاح
السفارة. صور لتدمير قوات روسيا
لهدف اوكراني في اقليم لوجانسك
واشنطن اراتو لانطونوف ان
السلطات الامريكية تعرقل عمل
تزود كييف بصواريخ ومدافع وذخائر
واعلن رئيس الوزراء البولندي ان
وزارة الدفاع الروسية اعلنت ان
قواتها الصاروخية والمدفعية نفذت
رغبة موسكو في السيطرة على دول
اخرى. قال السفير الروسي في
الروسية في الولايات المتحدة
وتابع السفير نتلقى تهديدات عبر
قواتها صدت اثني عشر هجوما روسيا
في الساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضية في مقاطعتي دونتسك
واللوجنسك شرقي البلاد. بوتين
استقطب الاهتمام. الحزمة الاخيرة
من المساعدات الامريكية لكييف
اراضي روسيا. وردا على وصف
اليابان جزر الكوريل بالاراضي
لم يكن موجودا منذ تقرير عام
الفين واحد عشر. رد روسي صارم.
المتحدث باسم الكريملين ديمتري
بيسكوف اكد ان الجزر في جنوب
الاقتصاد الروسي متماسك ومستمر
رغم العقوبات. زيلانسكي يحذر من
قوست وهي طائرات مسيرة طورتها
القوات الجوية الامريكية استجابة
تتضمن اكثر من مئة وعشرين طائرة
بدون طيار تكتيكيا من طراز فينكس
الهجوم بحسب جون كيربي. ولفت
كيربي الى ان نظام سيتطلب حدا
هذه الاسلحة. الاحداث اعلنت
قيادة الاركان الاوكرانية امس ان
ترى? سلاح جديد. طائرة من طراز
فينكس قوست او شبح العنقاء تدخل
الدول التي فرضت عقوبات على
روسيا على خلفية عملياتها
العسكرية الخاصة في اوكرانيا.
الذي ستؤول اليه هذه التوترات يا
ارخبيل الكوريل على الحدود مع
اليابان ستظل جزءا لا يتجزأ من
اليابان قالت ان الجزر هي جزء
متأصل من اراضي اليابان وهو وصف
الاقليمي مستمر منذ عقود مع
موسكو لتخرج طوكيو بذلك عن نهج
على خط الحرب الروسية في
اوكرانيا لتسجل دخولا استثنائيا
بشكل خاص لمتطلبات اوكرانيا
وتركيز هذه المسيرات الرئيسي هو
بشكل غير قانوني من قبل روسيا في
موقف متشدد من طوكيو تجاه نزاعها
مع اليابان. التي اصبحت دولة غير
صديقة. وذلك بعد ان انضمت الى
الامريكيين الى كييف خلال هذا
الاسبوع مستطردا لنعرف كيف
المحتلة. قال انه من الصعب
الحديث عن مواصلة محادثات السلام
ضد روسيا ها هي اليوم تعتبر ان
جزر الكوريلا الشمالية محتلة
التصالح تجاه روسيا الذي تعتمده
البلاد منذ عام الفين وثلاثة.
الساحة. اشتعال التوترات. بعد
انضمام اليابان للعقوبات الغربية
موجودة لفترة اطول بكثير من وجود
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين على
اوستن ان ما رأياه يظهر وكأن
الحياة بدأت بالعودة الى الوضع
الاوكرانيين. ولفت الى انه من
المقرر عودة الدبلوماسيين
الامن للاسلحة التي ترسلها الى
الاوكرانيين. اما وزير الخارجية
ستتكشف هذه الحرب. لكننا نعلم ان
المستقلة ذات السيادة ستكون
فيما فشلت روسيا في تحقيق
اهدافها باوكرانيا مؤكدا ان ما
الغواصات. كييف امنة. في تطور
لافت ظهر وزيرا الخارجية والدفاع
شاهده في شوارع كييف يعكس ان
معركتها قد حسمت لصالح
الطبيعي في كييف مؤكدا ان واشنطن
تسعى قدر المستطاع لضمان الوصول
انطوني بلينكن فقال ان واشنطن
وضعت استراتيجية لدعم اوكرانيا
الامريكيين في مؤتمر صحفي في
كييف وقال وزير الدفاع لويد
انها ستكون حادثة عابرة كخيانة
امريكا وبريطانيا لفرنسا في صفقة
الاوروبي. فهل تستمر الوحدة
الاوروبية بعد هذا التخاذل ام
باستخدام تقنية الباب الخلفي في
الحظر الذي يفرضه الاتحاد
دولار الى روسيا كجزء من ست
وسبعين رخصة تصدير. وسمحت باريس
بما في ذلك القنابل والصواريخ
والتي من المحتمل ان تستخدم في
نطاق الاتحاد الاوروبي على شحنات
الاسلحة الى روسيا والذي تم فرضه
فرنسا كانت مسؤولة عن ارسال
شحنات بقيمة مائة وستين مليون
جنوب لبنان نحو والجزائر تعلن
اكتفاء ذاتيا لقرابة العام.
في اعقاب ضم شبه جزيرة القرم عام
الفين واربعة عشر. كما تبين ان
للمصدرين بالوفاء بالعقود المتفق
عليها قبل الفين واربعة عشر
تحليل اوروبي كشف ان فرنسا
والمانيا ارسلتا معدات تضمنت
اوكرانيا. واوضحت الصحيفة في
تقرير حصري لها ان حصلت على
ظهور رسمي للحكومة الامريكية في
اوكرانيا في تحد واضح. اليابان
قنابل وصواريخ ومدافع الى موسكو
على الرغم من الحظر المفروض على
معدات عسكرية لموسكو بقيمة
مائتين وخمسة وتسعين مليون دولار
الذي يعنيه هذا? تبادل للاتهامات
بين روسيا من جهة والغرب
واوكرانيا وامريكا من جهة اخرى
وتستمر الحرب الباردة. في الوقت
تصف روسيا بالمحتلة وموسكو ترد.
فهل تندلع حرب بين موسكو وطوكيو
الباب الخلفي. اوردت صحيفة
البريطانية ان باريس برلين باعتا
الذي لم تتوقف فيه الحرب الساخنة
في اوكرانيا. صواريخ تنطلق من
الاسلحة لكييف. وبوتين يستعد
لنشر صواريخ الشيطان الاكبر. فما
تخاذل الماني فرنسي معاكس
لاوروبا في دعم لروسيا رغم
قريبا? سلاح امريكي يظهر لاول في
اوكرانيا وبولندا تواصل ضخ
اللحظة.
العقوبات. فهل يكون هذا التخاذل
سببا لكسر الوحدة الاوروبية? اول